let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com
jury finds amber heard defamed johnny
depp in trial verdict heard ordered to
pay 15 million dollars in damages but i
don't think that's where it ends
there's there's some there's some caps
and there's uh i think johnny johnny
does owe some to uh amber so let's read
the seven-person jury reached a decision
around 3 20 p.m on june 1st after
deliberating for a cumulative 12 hours
over three days
heard had been has been ordered to pay
15 million dollars in damages however
five million of the of that amount
applies to punitive damages with which
the state caps at 350 000.
in herds counter suit that was found
guilty of one of three counts of
defamation depp was not present in the
courtroom at the time the verdict was
read although he did teleconference in
from the united kingdom
depp filed the defamation suit against
herd for 50 million dollars after
alleging the op-ed she authored for the
washington post damaged his reputation
his legal teams at the actress presented
herself as a public figure representing
domestic abuse
which had financial consequences for her
ex-husband even though it never
specifically included his name and he's
won in a huge blow
for the metoo movement with all of these
just you know believe all women
narratives just no matter what well now
we know that amber heard wasn't being
honest and also the corporate press the
washington post that uncritically
ran this story which is what they often
do and then they what they want to hide
behind oh but it was someone else's
opinion
well here we are i don't know if i
missed anything in that story brett
there's more details you want to you
think we should mention uh the most
important one that i think a lot of
people leave out is that she didn't
write that's right
she uh it was drafted by an aclu lawyer
[Music]
whoa
and that was basically done uh to
coincide around the time of her uh
leaving uh johnny depp and uh we talked
about it today there's a lot of like
really um weasley language in that op-ed
like i was surprised how short it is
like i hadn't read it in a long time i i
skimmed it when it first came out right
and when we went back through it the
other day i mean it's only about a
paragraph it's a couple paragraphs long
and most of the stuff about johnny depp
could be inferred in like that first
paragraph and the rest of it is just
very very um generalized language so
that's why i was surprised that he
actually did end up winning so this
sounds like
a hoax
uh the i think it was you can write it
uh she did not write it she it was
drafted basically by somebody as an aclu
lawyer because she was a spokesperson
for the aclu on domestic violence wow um
and that's a problem because it was done
at the time of his uh of them getting
separated divorced this is this is more
than just me too and corporate press
this is a a hammer to the face of the
narrative machine i was i mean i don't
know if it's just because i'm like
pretty black-pilled about all of it but
i was very surprised that he like just
because the language was so vague and
done in such a way like without naming
him at all uh she wouldn't even she even
says like uh as a when she talks about
domestic violence she doesn't infer him
specifically like uh mary on the show
even positive she's like she could be
just saying what if she's just a
spokesperson for domestic violence not
necessarily somebody who has actually
had you know gone through domestic
violence i said yeah but who actually
does that who becomes a spokesperson for
something they didn't actually
experience right i'm curious
did anybody here know about this before
this defamation case came to negative oh
yeah yeah yeah you did i remember when
they published this story and it was
like who is she talking about they're
like she was obviously talking about
johnny depp so he then when he when he
got booted from pirates and what he got
booted from dumbledore yeah
from harry potter yeah well yeah from
fantastic beasts to find them that was
the one that i think is actually worse
but that they did him a favor to be
honest because it would be something yes
which is obviously maybe it would have
been good if johnny doubles in it you
know yeah yeah i'm kidding there's no
possible way
i'm good that was one of those things
where i was like that one felt more
realistic to me because that was dealing
with jk rowling who's a main producer
and writer on those movies which is
another reason because she can write
books she's not very she's not very good
at writing scripts that's uh yeah it's a
completely separate skill so but it's um
it's one of those things where she knows
what that's like to to deal with people
defaming her uh and saying stuff about
her beliefs so to have that come out and
have her not support him that felt more
uh
more tangible to me than the the stuff
about pirates this was three and a half
years ago she wrote this op-ed i spoke
up against sexual violence and faced our
culture's wrath that has to change and
it was not even drafted by her no this
is this is what the what the reality of
this country is these big machines these
the corporate press these big
non-profits these big ngos it's it's
fabricated it's a narrative machine
they're not they're not telling you
about reality it's completely
inauthentic she also never uh paid off
the she pledged the money from the from
her divorce settlement to
uh both the aclu and then what was the
other one it was a a hospital like a los
angeles children's hospital and she uh
said that she donated it but she did not
donate it she pledged the money and then
blamed johnny depp for saying well
you're suing me how can i give them the
money now because uh
i have to pay i may have to pay you back
so it's uh uh did you did anybody read
her um press release after
no it pulled it out it's it's aware it's
on our instagram right uh yeah uh hannah
claire sent me earlier yeah um
ridiculous
the gas lighting is real it's really bad
yep oh this is too long i don't care
about what she has to say
i mean i don't either that's fair um
here's what here's what's better in a
story from the babylon bee uncanceled
amber heard hired by the daily wire
good on you ben shapiro good on you
her and gina carrano can make a buddy
cop comedy oh my god this is this thing
from the babylon b was brilliant amber
heard hired by the daily wire a
brilliant move from co-ceo jeremy boring
on that one uh so
amber heard wrote the disappointment i
feel today is beyond words i'm
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still wasn't enough to stand up
to this disproportionate power influence
and sway of my ex-husband i'm even more
disappointed with what this verdict
means for other women it is a setback
they're they're i'm seeing a bunch of
progressives on twitter
and they're like
their audience is angry at this verdict
like they wanted johnny depp to lose
well you know what i think is actually
more damaging to women who are victims
of abuse
making dishonest claims about things
right that's all yeah that's right the
one thing you'll always hear in stories
like this is that when you lie and make
false accusations you're making it
harder for actual victims and i'm like
yeah we know that look people who lie
are bad people you know that's like the
cliched response hey amber heard your
garbage your garbage yeah my point is
that i mean look to
to pretend to care about a group of
people that you are allegedly pretending
to be one of as an imposter so you can
sort of use uh whatever social capital
you think being a victim will get you as
a porn like you don't actually care they
were like a couple alcoholic coke heads
that beat the hell out of each other i
mean they both deserve nothing out of
them in my opinion so that's why i guess
they're both they both won the lawsuit
for the other one got a counter suit so
she sued johnny for a couple million
bucks johnny got 10 out of her or 13 out
of her well he won the most of it
because she's worth more yeah because
men get paid more than women
maybe i don't know enough about this but
it seemed like he was trying to prove a
negative like what it seemed like this
trial proved was that both of them are
blackout crazy people like am i wrong in
that no that's that's right that's what
i got from it yeah but how do you defame
her so like i mean i guess he did in
that one count but she writes an article
yeah you know what i mean well but how
like you can you can be a crackpot
blackout drunk just don't go publish it
in the washington post the number one
conclusion we seem to come through is
that they were just really bad for each
other like their behavior was in general
just very self-destructive to one
another the problem with that is is
though uh we read we covered a story
yesterday where the media basically says
if you don't believe her you're bullying
her and that um and the the writer
posits that uh mutual abuse is fake that
there's no such thing as mutual abuse in
a relationship because of power dynamics
it always comes back to power dynamics
when they're discussing this stuff
communism that's a yes and they and they
actually make a point to talk about like
we can talk about uh you know like how
false accusations are extremely rare and
they you know they link your articles
like what you're supposed to go to and
it's two articles about kavanaugh
i was like i was like this is beyond
parody like the it's it's like so they
don't actually like you expect it to be
just
like some type of yougov statistics or
something that says yes it is in fact
rare for people to false falsely accuse
someone they always just fall back on
communism on well he had more power
that's why i lost that's what she says
in her thing the disproportionate power
influence and sway of my ex-husband it's
like dude well you did wrong you got
called out stop crying i don't know man
johnny depp does control the courts
that's true yeah yeah people don't
people don't realize that when they keep
putting george soros at the top it's
actually johnny depp actually johnny i
got the whole time
johnny depp can play george soros in the
george soros biopic when that eventually
doesn't get made a lot of people like to
talk about the shadow government what
they don't understand is that there is a
forward-facing government that
masquerades as
a court jester
and so you know the gesture is right
there the whole time you think there's a
shadow government it was a jester
pulling the strings right in front of
you see my problem with all this is i
don't think it's actually going to
change anything for society a lot of
people see this as a commentary on the
you know the relationships between men
and women how that's going to change i
said no this is just further proof that
we as a society are still obsessed with
celebrities and he has the money to
fight a 50 million defamation lawsuit if
this happens to just some regular dude
on the street who gets defamed he
doesn't have the money to fight this in
court it just it ends up the same way i
don't actually think it changes anything
long term maybe
well we live in a caste system yep
it's you know i feel like when this
country is founded it's very
meritocratic because a bunch of people
land on barren shores and it's like good
luck and then some of them are like well
we can steal it from the native
americans others were like we can work
with the native americans and others
were like guess i'll die i guess many
were like i'll survive and you know but
but that meritocracy was was all that
mattered so if you had problems you just
sought to solve it you tried to figure
it out now that we have big cities and
people aren't moving around anymore
we've become much less meritocratic now
you have people who are born rich stay
rich who can wield influence laws get
crafted around this and you end up with
regular people like cnn goes after that
guy who makes a meme yeah so some some
like doc worker who uh or some warehouse
worker who posted an email about nancy
pelosi they go after him he can't do
anything about it there's the one it was
like the wwe meme of like the guy like
powerbombing like the the cnn logo or
something like that and they were like
we'll reveal his name unless he promises
never to post a meme again
yeah exactly well they'll sit there and
do something like you know destroy a
teenager's life over a completely
fabricated story and repeat that he's
some kind of white supremacist who's
harassing a native american who was a
veteran um
when none of it's true and also tell the
entire country where the kid went to
school
while doing it while inciting hatred
against them then someone posts a meme
poking fun at them and they go i'm in
danger
so i don't mean to say in the most
extreme case cast system what i mean to
say is we're we're growing to this point
where you have people who are just third
generation wealthy they can afford big
lawyers they just
it's remarkable how
you know i've met people who are just
rich because their families were rich
and they buy things from each other with
insane amounts of money like i i would
be like you bought lotion for 50 bucks
why and they're like that's really good
and i'm like
you get the jergens from from walmart i
don't understand like why you would do
that and they're like i don't know but
then their friend
makes the lotion and sells it for 50
bucks and i'm like when you're in that
that community you just have all of this
money i guess from whatever and tim i
told you that lotion helps rejuvenate me
yeah i think this subtree thank you very
much
but you don't got to buy the fake weird
crazy expensive my point ultimately is
we're moving that direction i do think
we're still it's not it's not like
completely a cast system you can move up
the the class system but it really is
coming to that point where we have seen
so many people defamed i mean
james o'keefe may be one of the most
defamed people
and he has to fight tooth and nail and
ask people to help support him to win
these lawsuits which he does yeah johnny
depp is just ultra rich and he's like
jamming out in the uk like whatever and
then he wins when you've got that kind
of fu money you just write a blank check
to a lawyer and say win for me and then
you leave yeah i just want to be wealthy
enough that a false accusation against
me won't be able to stick yeah
even if he had lost i mean it's one of
those things where because he had won
the court of public opinion so handily
like say he loses but he has his
reputation back he can make that up in
money in roles in no time and pay off
that 100 million lawsuit if that had
been the way this had gone but i think
he would have ended up winning either
way because his reputation is now at the
very least he's employable again by big
studios he'll be able to make more money
again and that's just proof that uh it
keeps going where does it go from here
though like does he get a career back
because again
for me personally i didn't know anything
about this until the lawsuit i think
that's a lot of america just was like
holy cow johnny depp i don't know man
really he got booted from harry potter
and from pirates of the caribbean yeah
there's people in the know though i'm
talking about like the wider school and
i don't know maybe regular people know
about their entertainment
so like if you if you go to somebody and
you say do you know who hamilton was
they might be like uh
maybe you know johnny depp is like off
course yeah well yeah but i still never
heard of this all i know now is like
holy cow i know johnny depp is uh has
some
interesting problems uh and i didn't
know that before and so now i'm
wondering how does he go think about
this too like
you have a normal married couple that
divorces and the wife goes around
defaming the husband what does he do
about it well she told 15 people
their inner circle now you know he loses
some of his friends and then he moves on
and then she moves on in this weird
world of celebrity and wealth she
publishes an op-ed in the washington
post drafted by a lawyer for the aclu
they're both extremely wealthy
celebrities so this crazy cultural event
happens
yeah it's just weird
you know
yeah it was like uh where was the elaine
maxwell trial why was that not televised
i know like this is
this is the funniest thing about it we
have two celebrities wagging their
fingers at each other and everyone's
glued to it lawn crime network i think
had 150 000 people watching the verdict
get read i think it was
it was more than way more it was a
couple million
million no live no not electively no uh
collective views
i was watching at 500 000 people
watching okay 500 000 yeah yeah yeah
think about the maxwell trout they're
like no one's allowed in you can't know
about this like she's convicted of
trafficking on miners to a bunch who
know who knows we don't know anybody no
customers are gone and uh and that's
just like
i mean for i mean epstein himself like
we got questions about what happened in
that jail cell gone but johnny depp
top of the hour headline headline
headline bread and circus you know that
that roman tactic to keep the population
uh subdued you know they have enough
enough
so here's what i want to point out
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you